how has fashion and fragrance brand dior
responded to the public legal battles of
one of their key spokesman johnny depp
and have ads for the fragrance he
endorses sauvage corded controversy keep
watching
in 2020 depp lost a libel case against
the british tabloid the sun which
claimed that depp physically harmed his
then-wife amber heard and called him a
wifebeater according to variety the
judge ruled although he has proved the
necessary elements of his cause of
action in libel the defendants have
shown that what they published in the
meaning which i have held the words to
bear was substantially true even with
that ruling dior continued to stand by
death the move angered many but
commentators weren't that surprised
british public relations veteran mark
borkowski told the guardian brands hope
for short-term memory loss and long-term
amnesia these fashion companies live in
their own bubble it's like the devil
wears prada they live in a world where
they are used to facing controversy the
newspaper noted that interest in sauvage
had seemingly increased following the
libel case and that those who were
supporting depp were pledging to buy it
dior stood by johnny depp but hollywood
didn't despite initially receiving the
support of harry potter author jk
rowling the actor was fired from his
role as gallard grindelwald in the
fantastic beasts films before warner
brothers made the news official depp
released a statement on instagram
telling his followers that he was asked
to resign grindelwald wasn't the only
major part that depp lost either it
appears that his time as the wildly
successful pirates of the caribbean
character captain jack sparrow is also
over the daily mail first reported that
disney was retiring depp's jack sparrow
back in 2018. the actor was asked about
the article when he was cross-examined
by heard's attorney during the trial for
depp's 50 million defamation suit
against his now ex-wife he said he
wasn't aware of the report but wasn't
surprised by it considering two years
had gone by of constant
um
worldwide talk about me being this wife
peter depp went on to say he's sure
disney was cutting ties to be safe and
that he wouldn't reprise the role of
sparrow even if disney offered him the
chance
if dior could have foreseen johnny
depp's future when they hired him as the
face of sauvage would the company have
reconsidered perhaps not because the
french giant appears to be reaping the
rewards of digging in its heels author
and broadcaster katie edwards wrote in
the independent dior have been smart at
a time when many celebrities scream
cancel culture anytime they're
criticized or called to account for
their comments or behavior the team at
dior seem to recognize that controversy
can drive sales one thing dior can't
escape though is the fact that the name
could be interpreted as pretty awkward
sauvage can mean savage wild and fierce
according to collins it's worth noting
that depp became the ambassador for the
fragrance back in 2015 before the
accusations of domestic violence and
legal proceedings
in 2019 a sauvage commercial titled we
are the land was criticized for its
portrayal of native americans in it depp
plays guitar as a member of the rosebud
sioux tribe performs a warrior dance in
full traditional guard people were quick
to say that using native american
imagery in support of a fragrance called
sauvage was offensive in this instance
dior was quick to back down pulling the
ad from social media only a few hours
after posting it dior said in a
statement recently a film trailer for
the sauvage fragrance was posted on
social media and immediately withdrawn
we are deeply sorry for any offense
caused by this new advertising campaign
which was meant to be a celebration of
the beauty dignity and grace of the
contemporary native american culture it
was a film
made out of great respect and made with
great respect and with love for for the
native american peoples the hollywood
reporter notes that depp says he has
native american heritage and that he was
adopted by the comanche tribe ahead of
playing tanto in the lone ranger
despite the various controversies
sauvage has continued to sell according
to the beauty website cosmetify the
number of people searching for sauvage
online increased by 23 after depp's case
against the sun was dismissed the
guardian noted that sauvage was still
the number one best-selling cologne at
the fragrance shop at the time depp's
defamation suit against herd hasn't
slowed the fragrance down in 2022 marie
claire revealed that sauvage had become
the best selling perfume in the world
writing a bottle of dior sauvage was
sold every three seconds in 2021 making
it the best selling perfume in both the
male and female categories this is the
first time men's fragrance has taken the
worldwide first place spot however since
its initial launch in 2015 it has seen
continued success globally
there's no denying that johnny depp has
left his mark on pop culture through his
portrayals of classic characters
including jack sparrow edward
scissorhands sweeney todd and more he is
amassed a legion of loyal fans according
to the guardian depp's fans have had his
back since he sued the sun over its
wife-beater claims they showed up with
their signs at court and created the
justice for johnny depp hashtag to
discuss everything from the libel case
to the counter-accusations of domestic
violence he made against herd i can see
more of johnny's side on this it appears
as though people wanting to show support
for the actor have taken to buying a
bottle of sauvage as a way of doing so
one supporter wrote johnny depp is still
the face of sauvage because dior aren't
idiots another said shout out to dior
for practically being the one sponsor
left for johnny depp that hasn't turned
their back on him he's still the face of
their cologne sauvage definitely gonna
get me a bottle to show my support dior
banked on depp's fans staying faithful
and the gamble has been paying off big
time if you or someone you know is
dealing with domestic abuse you can call
the national domestic violence hotline
at 1-800-799-7233
you can also find more information
resources and support at their website
[Music]